como lo adelantamos nuestro tema del día
es la polémica desatada tras las
declaraciones en el senado de eeuu de la
desempleada de facebook francis javi
quien aseguró que la compañía presionaba
por mayores ganancias sin importar los
derechos de los usuarios con un énfasis
especial en atraer a los niños ante esto
mark zuckerberg negó que las cosas en la
empresa ocurran de esa forma como ella
lo describió y que sólo trabajó con
ellos durante dos años hagen previamente
filtró estos documentos internos de la
compañía al diario the wall street
journal donde asegura que el gigante de
las redes sociales antepone sus
beneficios a la seguridad de los
usuarios y también oculta que sus
plataformas son nocivas para los menores
fomentan la división social y debilitan
la democracia eso dice joven vamos ahora
con nuestro primer invitado el está mi
de stefan sí o de
tetera y consultor de transformación
digital gracias a mí por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
empezamos a preguntándole los derechos
que tiene una empresa como facebook el
contenido de las redes social los
deberes que tienen este tipo de empresas
que trabajan además con nosotros con los
usuarios
ahorita creo que lo mencionaba un poco
rosa y es al final del día nosotros
hemos decidido entregarle nuestra
información para las redes sociales a
cambio de un servicio que muchos de
nosotros creemos que hace sentido y que
nos entrega valor el tema es qué hace la
compañía con esa información cómo
utiliza esa información nuestra para su
propio beneficio y cómo nos cuida de
nosotros mismos y de los que nos rodean
samir que somos nosotros para facebook
en ese orden de ideas
el producto muchos de nosotros creemos
que somos los usuarios y es en parte
cierto pero nosotros somos el producto
la compañía vende publicidad vende
publicidad hiper hiper dirigida y para
eso nosotros le entregamos nuestra
información para que ellos creen unos
perfiles completos acerca de nuestros
gustos de nuestros intereses que luego
le venden a sus pauta antes para
mostrarnos publicidad que cada día nos
interesa más o sea es decir que ese es
el modelo de negocios que utilizan las
compañías como facebook o instagram o
incluso whatsapp cierto en realidad
cualquier compañía hoy en el mundo
digital que no te está cobrando por su
servicio lo que está haciendo es que se
está usando tu información para para
lucrarse con terceros es decir el
producto eres tú pero como se lucra
saque que vende de nuestra imagen de
nuestro contenido
aquí hay aquí hay un buen ejemplo y es
cuando tú sales a la calle y ves una
valla publicitaria quién puso esa valla
publicitaria tomó la decisión de ponerla
ahí porque seguramente hay un tráfico
importante y entonces le apuestan a que
pase por enfrente de esa valla o un
porcentaje de gente a quien el producto
que está mostrando les sea interesante
en el caso de facebook el modelo es al
revés el modelo es que te interesa a ti
al detalle durante años hemos venido
dando la información a facebook con
nuestros clicks con nuestros likes con
lo que posteamos con los sitios que
visitamos con las cosas que buscamos
creo que para nadie es un secreto que
uno por ejemplo busca el viaje a parís
sí y en los siguientes días a lo largo y
ancho del internet vas a ver publicidad
de restaurantes en parís de vuelos a
parís de hoteles en parís de cosas para
hacer en país sencillamente lo que le
estamos entregando a las redes sociales
es ese sentido de que nos interesa
cuáles son nuestros intereses para y
ellos entonces salgo en donde los paot
antes y les digan usted a quien le
quiere llegar le quiere llegar a una
persona entre tal y tal edad con tales y
tales intereses ubicada en tal sitio yo
se lo tengo y le muestra entonces a uno
esa publicidad publicidad que como es
más afín a cada uno de los usuarios es
más común y es más posible que la gente
le dé like y termine comprando el
producto es decir a eso le podemos
llamar entonces la economía de
vigilancia eso es legal digamos eso uno
lo acepta cuando se abre un perfil en
una red social ellos pueden hacer lo que
quieran de alguna de alguna manera con
nuestra información con nuestra pues sí
con nuestros gustos deseos si ni
siquiera es poder hacer lo que quieran
pero efectivamente como lo decías
ahorita en el momento en que uno abre
una una cuenta en una red social si uno
revisa lo que dicen los términos y
condiciones
uno básicamente lo que le está diciendo
a las redes sociales yo le voy a
entregar a usted mi información para que
usted con ella cree un perfil detallado
mío y con eso usted me pueda ofrecer
publicidad u otros servicios vivimos en
realidad en eso que mencionas la
economía de la vigilancia una economía
que está basada en poder crear perfiles
completos de los usuarios seguirlos en
el mundo digital e incluso en el mundo
físico para ver qué hacen qué que buscan
que les interesa que no les interesa y
con eso vendernos esa publicidad ahora
samir entonces digamos que por qué tanta
polémica ahora cuando nosotros como
usuarios cuando accedemos cuando abrimos
un perfil de una red social pues estamos
accediendo a todo eso porque tanta
polémica realmente es culpa de nosotros
o de facebook o imagino que es la
pregunta del millón difícil de responder
pero ciertamente también nosotros
aceptamos unos términos y condiciones
cuando accedemos a abrirnos una
plataforma como ésta un perfil
en gran parte es culpa nuestra que no
leemos y que no entendemos lo que
estamos usando pero lo que está pasando
en estas últimas en estas últimas
semanas tiene que ver más allá en como
la compañía ha decidido romper sus
propias negras reglas empujar sus
propios límites con fines digamos y
claramente
financieros incluso a costa de la
estabilidad democrática en algunos
países la estabilidad emocional de
algunos usuarios
sencillamente al entender que moviendo
moviendo esas mismas reglas que existían
podían por lo menos el generar más
tracción generar más gente que se queda
en la plataforma generar más likes y
generar más engage samil se puede
manejar un tipo de marketing considerado
ético
sí yo creo que sí y de nuevo
lamentablemente en estos últimos 10 años
nos hemos metido en un modelo que no es
que raya en lo ético sino que creo que
ha llegado al punto en el que los
usuarios al final no saben qué significa
cuando le dan like cuando le dan un
tweet cuando abren una cuenta cuando
aceptan unos términos y condiciones sin
leer y no entienden la información que
están entregando a cambio de ese
servicio y digamos nosotros ante
etcétera siempre el símbolo mismo es no
es que facebook sea malo no es que sea
bueno usted tiene que entender que le
está entregando al servicio antes de
usted poder decir si lo que va a recibir
a cambio hace sentir a samir treinta
segundos muy rápido cómo se puede
solucionar esto hacia dónde vamos
regulación y creo que lo que vimos ayer
en el senado de los eeuu
vamos a ver pasos grandes de regulación
no sólo hacia facebook sino hacia todos
los modelos de redes sociales por lo
menos en eeuu pues a mí gracias por su
tiempo y por estar con nosotros en
directo américa en francés 24 feliz
resto día muchas gracias un feliz día
para todos